your life is so colorful well it's
interesting there's a lot of psychology
with color and a lot of energetic stuff
with color if you think about chakras
and chakra tune men spirit science says
this really well they have like this 42
minutes series on chakras and they say
if you want to take in the energy of a
certain chakra like your core for will
or red for passion root grounding where
that color be surrounded by it so it
goes a step further if you wear all
colors you can sense feel see and bring
in and a lot of times when people bring
all back what they don't know is they're
insulating themselves an urge ethically
so we may not be taking energy in and we
may not be putting energy out it can be
protective but can also be kind of
really like isolating not really pulling
that stuff in and if you think about the
personalities and the vibes of people
you know who walk into a room just all
black suits versus the bright colorful
stuff yeah yours a lot that can be done
this you're already growing right into
and I love it I love it